[Music]
two months ago we saw a really distinct
style of protest in the form of
extinction rebellion I'm sure you've got
a lot to say about this but yesterday it
was announced that the men are going to
try and push prosecution on all of the
activists 1,100 actors who were arrested
now I saw a Facebook post that reference
Mahatma Gandhi first they ignore you
first they ridicule you then they fight
you then we win yeah well it's going to
take a little bit of time to win because
we're not just up against the state nor
even is the state the biggest enemy of X
are all of the other groups like me too
or black lives matter even black lives
matter it's that the problem is what
what the German philosopher Hannah
Arendt called the temporary alliance of
the elite and the mob and we're up
against a temporary alliance of
authoritarian elites who keep their
money offshore who are heavily invested
in fossil fuels surveillance
technologies yeah these what these guys
and of course by investing in offshore
that is anti taxation they're
effectively investing in anti society no
that's on one hand there are large
numbers of people who need to believe
that climate change is not real who need
to believe that women are subordinate to
men because in their their world will
disintegrate in the next 20 years
because of the changes really to make
your generation cannot go back into the
box that my grandmother's generation of
women could had to live in or gay men or
transgender people or black people
isn't where you can't D Network a
society you can't unliberated generation
ok so X are for me is the latest
iteration of the new kind of protest
that is there almost a son and daughter
of 2011 and the Occupy movement the
Occupy movement imagined a new society
and we assembled the forms of that
society on the Internet the networks and
then we took it into physical space in
the form of tent camps and square
occupations they didn't last they were
easily repressed extinction rebellion me
too and black lives matter take it to a
visceral level to a granular level do
you think about what BLM is saying is
that the wages of whiteness is that ever
policeman arrives on a trouble see
black people get shot of white people
generally don't that's why these races
spend all their time on the phone trying
to call the cops on black people for
selling water on the street what they
call is the cop will arrive and shoot
somebody and it ain't gonna be them no
that's a very different thing that's
saying I need civil rights
I need civil rights for Martin Luther
King for Malcolm X etc Stokely
Carmichael was real Angela Davis was
real was a real thing but to say you no
longer have the right to shoot me when
the cops turn up he's a different more
granular thing it demands changes of
human behavior me too demands the change
in human behavior I work in the theater
sometimes the theater is undergoing a
revolution because of the demand of
female actors and producers no longer
for their physical invasion of their
body space under the excuse of the
theater I'm not just talking about
directors saying you know let's let's
have a drink after work you know by the
way you'll get a lovely part in my next
film no it's about the actual
physicality of theater is changing
there's no a movement that helps people
act through whether they have to do a
sex scene or a sexual violence scene
both these things exist in reality and
should be portrayed on stage but now we
have movements where we mediate those
and we allow people to explore what is
happening to them in a much more
reflected way reflective way than before
so one describing though is the way me
too is not just transforming kind of the
agenda of feminism it's transforming in
a real industry it's also transforming
parts of corporate life not enough there
are no tests and courses they call them
the Weinstein test in corporate life you
can you pass the test otherwise you
don't become a director of this bank so
the amazing thing is that going back to
XR that we've got here what's X ARS
number one demand tell the truth we're
at a philosophy festival we're routinely
people question the possibility of truth
but I don't and I think that's another
thing there are truths they are
provisional they're scientifically
verified we need to fight for them and
I'm delighted at the XR as come out of
course the states are going to repress
it it's gonna be wake up time when some
quite you know I
I'd say you know you're young and
therefore inexperienced protesters my
generation of climate protesters the
people I collaborated with them reported
on I've been trying to say Luke the cops
will come soon there will be people
arriving in your camps who look unstable
you need to deal with them you need in a
good way you know we dedicate and care
for people but what the cops then do is
that they like the evil doctor they look
they look at the thing and they go
that's an entity and this occasionally
doesn't have to be our police another
country's police it can be a private
security company you've never heard of
they say what are the what are the
illnesses and weaknesses of this thing
how can we make them worse
that's what happens that's what happened
to the tent camp outside alone the stock
exchange that it was quite clear
somebody was exacerbating all the
problems and I don't believe it's the
British stage I believe you know that
the whole world is know a kind of out
sourced there's a kind of state
mischief-making that's outsourced to
private companies we've never heard of
you saw it around Cambridge analytical
and its parent company but we can we can
defeat them we are millions of people
and one is more they have sons and
daughters who don't want to live in a
burning planet so in the end we can have
an argument we even with the kind of
shittiest private intelligence company
do you really want to live on a burning
planet with chaos with millions of
refugees unstoppably moving from the
global south to the north if you want to
live in that planet go on disrupting the
climate change movement if you don't
then even it might you know you don't
like people with green hair and nose
rings fine just do it yourself
lobby your Tory MP or your Republican
Congress person tell them to stop
funding climate chaos for more debates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the Institute's of Arts and ideas at IAI
TV
you